[موسيقى]
هنا t-minus 45
دقيقة وهنا يأتي رواد الفضاء
هناك وترى جيف بيزوس في
المقدمة
أوليفر دامون وهو يدخل طاقم الشريط
سبعة كيفن ستروب هناك
على اليمين
وكذلك والي فانك يا لها من لحظة بالنسبة
لها حسنًا والي  وهناك يتم تحميلها
في حالة تمزق
بينما كان جزءًا من برنامج Mercury 13
في
الستينيات وسيتوقفون على اليسار هناك
وهم يتجهون إلى الطريق إلى الفضاء
حقًا ، هذه هي الصفقة الحقيقية التي كنت
أبذل قصارى جهدي من أجلها  احتوى على لحظة فتاة المعجبين الخاصة بي
هناك لأنها مرة أخرى
مصدر إلهام لكثير من الأشخاص
حول العالم ومن بينهم أنا
نرى هنا
أن رواد الفضاء بدأوا في
الصعود
إلى برج الطاقم هناك يلوحون بالولاء وهي
تقود الطاقم ،
مرحبًا بك مرة أخرى.
مرة أخرى هنا على المكتب لمساعدتك
في اللعب عن طريق اللعب هنا ،
رأينا للتو منذ لحظة آه أنهم كانوا
يقودون سياراتهم حول الطريق الدائري
توقفوا عن التقاط صورة لأنك بالطبع
تعلم أنك فهمت أننا
سنكون أكثر  إحياء ذكرى هذه اللحظة قدر
المستطاع لرواد الفضاء هؤلاء ، فهم
يستحقون ذلك ،
لذا عند صعود البرج لدينا
والي ، يبدو أن جيف بيزوس مارك وأوليفر
ديمون يتجهان إلى صاروخهما
لن نتمتع بهذه الثقة
بدون برنامج شيبرد الجديد
تمامًا
وجاريت جونز مرة أخرى الذي يقود
برنامج جلين الجديد بالكامل ،
إنه أه لديه وظيفة كبيرة لكنه
حصل على الكثير من المساعدة ، لقد حصل على
هذه المساعدة المنجنيقة
من التطوير والآن
العمليات في الرحلة لذا
يحتوي الملجأ على وظيفتين رئيسيتين
، وهو ملجأ في حالة
حدوث نوع من حالات الطوارئ إذا
احتاجوا إلى إخلاء الكبسولة بسرعة كبيرة جدًا ،
فيمكنهم عبور الجسر على بعد 75
قدمًا فقط ويكونون في هذا الملجأ سريعًا جدًا
وهو مقاوم للحريق ويمكنه التعامل معه  مجموعة كاملة
من الحالات الشاذة التي قد تحدث مع
الصاروخ ،
دعونا نشاهدهم وهم يستعدون لعبور
الجسر ،
ما هي لحظة جيف بيزوس
مارك بيزوس
والي فونك
وأوليفر دامون يرنان الرئيس.  يصدر الجرس التذكاري
بعض الضجيج في طريقهم للوصول
إلى كبسولة الطاقم
التي تريد العودة إلى مقعدك من
الصفر ، وهذا أمر مهم للغاية ،
دعونا نشاهده هنا وهم يعبرون جسر
الرافعة ويلتقطون بعض
الصور النهائية ، لدينا
مصورنا هناك فيليكس كونس
المصور اللامع الذي
التقط تلك اللقطات الجميلة
للطاقم التي رأيناها
سابقًا وهناك يذهبون إلى كبسولة الطاقم